[Music]
Harry Styles is gearing up for a new
solo era here's what we know
first the one direction singer released
this teaser video this week we see him
with short hair from behind walking
towards a door and as he opens it bright
white light themes out and then after
his April 7th release of what many fans
assumes as first single Harry's on the
April fifteenth episode of SNL and since
Jimmy Fallon is also slated it looks
like Harry is the musical guest you've
never seen it look so easy Harry
uploaded this new Twitter profile pic
switched up his personal website and
check out his Instagram three new white
boxes this week seems to represent a
clean slate no word on what Harry solo
music will sound like but here's what he
said in the past oversee write a lot of
stuff from personal experience but and
you know people get interpret a lot of
different things in in different ways
now one direction upholds they're just
on a break here's what Harry told ET
about that after they made the
announcement in 2015 I think it's
important for us to to take the break
and have it as a break obviously like
now said before we've done five albums
five tours in five years which compared
to most of the artists is is quite a
large rate of kind of doing it so I
think all we've really said is is that
we're not gonna do that next year and
that's all we've said and obviously you
know it'd be naive of us to think that
people aren't going to read instead
looks like after that 2016 break Harry
is ready to take on 2017 solo baby a
perfect for you
[Music]